- GET READY
FOR MAGIC TIME, PEOPLE.
I'LL ACTUALLY BE GUIDING
THE ASTRONAUTS
DOWN AS WE SPEAK.
- MISSION CONTROL,
THIS IS APOLLO.
WE ARE GO FOR LANDING
IN FOUR...
THREE...
TWO...
ONE.
- EXTEND PODS.
AND...
MAGIC!
- AND WE HAVE TOUCHDOWN.
- WE HAVE LANDED ON MARS.
[cheers]
KURT THOREAU, EVERYONE.
- HOW IS STEVE MISSING THIS?
WHERE THE HELL IS HE?
- [screams]
GET AWAY FROM ME,
OCTOPUS MIME!
[upbeat polka music]
♪
[screams]
[truck roars]
[grunting]
AGH!
AAH!
- I THINK YOU'LL LIKE
THE FIRST WORDS
MAN WILL SAY ON MARS.
I COMPOSED THEM MYSELF.
- THAT WAS
ONE SMALL STEP FOR MAN
AND ONE GIANT--
SHIT!
- [screams]
[babbling nonsensically]
[people screaming]
- WE CAN EASILY
REATTACH THESE
AS LONG AS WE'RE VERY,
VERY CAREFUL WITH THEM--
WHOA!
[chuckles]
SO THAT'S WHY
WE SHOULDN'T PUT THOSE
IN HERE.
[rangers scream]
- WAIT A MINUTE.
THAT FAT ALIEN
LOOKS LIKE STEVE.
- THAT FAT ALIEN IS STEVE.
- HOW'D STEVE GET TO MARS?
- STEVE ISN'T ON MARS.
[gasps]
THAT MEANS THE MARS LANDING--
- IT'S ALL A GODDAMN FAKE!
[laughs]
I KNEW IT!
WE'RE ASS-DEEP IN THE BIGGEST
CONSPIRACY EVER!
- GUARDS, SEIZE THEM!
- OH, WHAT?
YOU ACTORS
GONNA HOLD US HOSTAGE
WITH A BUNCH OF
PHONY PROP GUNS?
WOW, THAT'S REALISTIC.
FAKE BRAINS TOO.